always use this to attack Christians
when they it's in first Colossians when
they go about there's a verse Colossians
115 yes yes how do you combat that man
because it seems pretty clear man I've
been answering that for the past month
but I'll answer it again go to
Colossians 1:5 the objection by those
Witnesses yes that's their main tool and
I'll show you how dishonest they are I
don't know if you have one of their
Bibles no I just have ESV and KGB okay
Colossians 1:15
I'm going to read it from the neural
translation okay it says he is the image
of the invisible God the firstborn of
all creation that's the one right yeah
okay so there it says Jesus is the
firstborn of all creation doesn't that
mean that he's created okay no it
doesn't because I want you to read for
me Colossians 1:5 Now read 16 for me for
by him all things were created in heaven
and on Earth visible and invisible
whether Thrones or dominions or rulers
or authorities all things are created
through him and for him now let me ask
you a question if verse
16 Paul tells us that by Jesus Christ
all things were created in heaven and on
Earth whether visible or invisible
whether Thrones dominions principalities
Powers authorities all things were
created through and for him doesn't that
mean that Jesus exists before all things
were
created that's what it looks like I
guess they just Target that verse 15 is
what they they hang on to that yeah but
now you have them read 16 say so Jesus
was there before all things were created
right well all things is all creation
right yes so if Jesus exists before all
creation when was he
created he must be before like he was he
was before the the universe started but
it's not just Universe it's everything
all things is not just the physical
Universe I don't get how they can reject
the Trinity I mean John 1:1 seems pretty
no they they mistranslate that don't go
to John 1:1 yet focus on Colossians 1
because they mistranslate that in
Colossians 1:16 all things were created
by Him in heaven and on Earth whether
visible or invisible Thrones Powers
dominions principalities all things were
created through him and for him so and
focus on my question okay if Jesus
created all things that's all creation
right that means he exists before all
creation right yes then can he be
created no
that's impossible right because if you
exist before all creation you're not
created right that's right now read
verse 17 to make it clear verse
17 and he is before all things there you
go and he's before all things and in him
all things hold together so verse 17
says not only did Jesus create all
things in heaven on Earth and all things
were created for him he is present tense
before all things he is transcended over
all things and exist before all things
and in him meaning the power that
sustains all creation gives life to all
creation is the power that resides in
him that power is in him and from him so
Jesus is the creator sustainer of all
creation
right so then how can he be
created how can he be right that means
he can't be
right so they kind of ignore the rest of
that parad
you know what they do they add the word
other four times they deliberately
butcher the Greek so now let me show you
how they translate it in their Bible
firstborn can you post Colossians 1:1
1617 in their Bible now notice what they
do notice what I'm going to send you a
link to show you that even their own
Greek text they use doesn't have the
word but watch here what they do to
deceive people firstborn now watch here
because by means of him all other things
were created in the heavens and the
Earth the things visible and things
invisible whether they are Thrones or
Lordships or governments or authorities
all other things have been created
through him and for him also he is
before all other things and by means of
him all other things exist four times
they added the word other in their
English translation now I'm going to
give you the link and I'm going to give
you the link you in the in the comment
section and you in the in the section on
Skype now watch here here is their
online Bible okay let me get it for you
so you can read online hold on let me
get the link you guys are going to read
their Greek Interlinear you're going to
see in the Greek the word other is not
there they inserted the word other four
times to make it seem Jesus didn't
create every cre thing in the entire
creation because they knew that would be
a contradiction because if he created
every single thing in entire creation
then he has to be uncreated eternal so
they couldn't let that stand so here it
is the in Greek Interlinear I'm going to
give you guys the link then I'm G to
explain what firstborn means Colossians
and I have YouTube sessions on this go
watch those YouTube sessions because I
go in depth now here is Colossians 1
here's the link to 16 you guys can get
there on your own but I'm going to make
it quick for you and I'm going to read
what the Greek says I mean not the Greek
but the English translation of the Greek
and brother I want you to go there and
see it for
yourself tell me if you see the word
other there here it is now guys click on
it here's what their Interlinear the
English translation of the Greek says
here I'm reading the English words to
their Greek now here is the Greek I'll
read it for
youti t p okay now English translation
because in him it was created the all
even their inter shows that the Greek
says the all the word other is not
there you guys confirm it where's the
word
other other side they deliberately
changed the whole Bible yes say it again
brother they did what they they added
things to the Bible to take out its
original meaning for their own objective
that sounds quite satanic say it again
that sounds what
satanic demonic that's how you know this
organization is from the pit of Hell
because they've added to the word of God
and taken away from the word of God and
glory to God because the
original the manuscripts of the books of
the Bible we have copies in the original
languages of these books Greek for the
New Testament Hebrew Aramaic for the Old
Testament we can show them hold on the
very Greek text that you translate from
it says
T the word other is not there how dare
you insert
right okay so now if we just go by what
the actual wording is Jesus Christ
created all things not all other things
all things were created through him and
for him in heaven on Earth whether
visible or invisible where the Thrones
dominions Powers principalities he is
before all things and in him that
creative power that sustains all things
is in him he sustains all things he has
to be older than all creation he must
have been there before all creation well
if he was there before all creation he
is uncreated eternal and not a creature
so then what does firstborn mean then
let me explain it to you real quickly
are you
ready yeah let's do it firstborn can
have one of three meanings it can mean
the one born
first or the one who's the heir and the
one who's preeminent Supreme Over the
rest because biblically if you're the
firstborn you're the heir and you are
Supreme Over the rest meaning if you're
the first son you are higher than the
other children and you're the heir So In
Time the Bible started using the word
first form to emphasize a person's
status as being Superior to others or
the one who's the heir let me just give
you one example go to Psalm 89 verses 19
and
20 of old you spoke in Aion to your
Godly one and said I have granted help
to no one who is mighty exalted no I've
exalted one chosen from the
people I have found David my servant
with my holy oil I have anointed him so
who's he talking
about who's he talking
about David David right he's talking
about David right that's right okay so
David So guys notice he's talking about
David Now read verses 2627 what does God
say about David
okay uh 26 he shall cry to me you are my
father my God and the rock of my
salvation and I will make him the
firstborn and the highest of the kings
of the earth now notice what God says
about David David was the youngest of
eight Sons Jess's father had eight Sons
he was the youngest of eight and David
wasn't the first king of Israel Saul was
king before him you see what he said
about David folks he said I will make
David my firstborn the highest of the
kings of the earth what does it mean for
David to be the firstborn he wasn't the
first son born he was the youngest of
eight he wasn't the first king of Israel
so what does it mean he's the first
born in what sense is he the
firstborn what can firstborn
mean the first one that God chose to to
do his mission no Saul was chosen others
no man what did I say the definition of
firstborn was so there three definitions
right yeah what were they which one do
you think applies to this one well what
were the
three you remember I think I was turning
the page while you were explaining okay
the three meanings of firstborn would be
think about it firstborn means you are
you if you're the firstborn of your
family that means you're
what the eldest yes so the one born
first yeah and if you're the one born
first that
means you have the highest position in
the family right that's right and you're
the heir right that's right the
inheritance is yours well since David
isn't the one born first he's the
youngest of eight sons and he isn't the
first king of Israel then what does it
mean that he is the firstborn God's
first born
so he's the highest position in a family
then but not not a family because it's
not his family but what is he
then the highest position you got it he
says it right there the highest of the
kings of the Earth the one who's
preeminent right so why is Jesus called
the firstborn of all creation not
because he's the first one created but
because he's Supreme Over
creation Transcendent over creation
Superior preeminent over creation by
virtue of being the creator of creation
who owns creation because it says all
things were created for
him hey uh that's fantastic I appreciate
it Sam I just needed to uh learn about
that Colossians paragraph
because it makes sense I appreciate it
thank you much Brother anytime you have
more questions call me but go to my
YouTube channel type in firstborn you'll
have videos that pop up go to answering
Islam blog.com wordpress.com put in
Joe's Witnesses I have dozens of
Articles all of this detail so you can
study meticulously you can print them
out upload them to your you know your
website or YouTube channel use it in
Hong Kong disseminate it for the glory
of Jesus all right thanks Sam cheers
have a good one God bless you take care